[Music]
so gordon ramsay
is really really freaking out the tick
tock generation why
because he's always doing tick tocks
with his daughter no or he's saying
[ __ ] crazy ass [ __ ] no
what do you guys think he did
crazy ass [ __ ] with his daughter it's
gotta be food related right yeah he's
he's pissing off all the food craters on
tiktok i actually liked them more when i
saw the tick tocks with his daughter do
you yeah because what kind of tic tacs
does he do she she pranked them like she
made him look in the [ __ ] water with
the egg and [ __ ] and she smashed the egg
on his head
and then so like
you know he's so mad and [ __ ] serious
but then the way he treats his daughter
you're just like oh this guy's just a
normal [ __ ] dude dude have you seen
the cooking show where he does all kids
he's way different he's like the
sweetest [ __ ] guy is he actually what
a two-face yeah he's fake and then when
he sees the the adults he's like you
[ __ ] pig with all the kids he's like
oh it's okay no worries he's like the
sweetest guy dude my favorite bit
everyone's seen this but he puts two
buns around this lady's head and he's
like what are you and she's like i'm an
idiot
she shouldn't have burned the [ __ ]
the look on her face is so perfect it's
like when we roast anthony has that
perfect look on his face of like yeah
the shoulder shrug [ __ ] great is that
you look anthony does it better than
anybody he's the best at getting roasted
out about any of us by far because he
gives that look that look that one that
one i want to make into a sticker and
put on the back of my laptop tick
tockers
or uh
because this generation's a whole
generation [ __ ] [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] so i thought it was
probably because the way he speaks to
people close but yeah this is about how
the generations maybe [ __ ] has
[ __ ] but i do want to get you
guys thoughts on this because well you
guys i already know what you guys are
going to think but here we go
is that a sheep
did you even [ __ ] drop kick the lamb
dude
[Laughter]
he's like what's going in the oven first
what do you say yummy yum yum who am i
going to cook first
[Music]
so let me guess people are they got
their feelings hurt because he's talking
to all these really cute animals
in this way
and then they're
man i think people were just delusional
dude it's the [ __ ] vegans dude vegans
dude imagine taking the tick tock
generation to 99 ranch
where you see the fish [ __ ] swimming
dude yeah well you gotta pick up the
lobster and she'll like they'll be like
that one
my dad only goes to asian supermarkets
because why do i go to america when
they're all dead
so he only goes to the asian
supermarkets because you point at the
one you want oh i won that one and then
that depressed one is like yay kill me
let me die i cannot stop right cause you
always picked like the lively ones right
yeah yeah that's so [ __ ] funny even
at the chinese restaurant you want to
get lobster you know how they come they
always pull them out with the [ __ ]
bucket they'll go which one
you're like oh i want that one and that
[ __ ] is still like moving around
and [ __ ] and then you're like hey
they're sentient beans you're not sad
you know like [ __ ] it it still tastes
good what um
what are they saying it's just the same
vegan [ __ ] like it's not that about
initially vegan just cruel it's like
it's cruelty
that he's like he's like oh
like come here i'm hungry he's gonna eat
the [ __ ] that's what he's gonna
do well he's you know he shouldn't be
hurting the feelings of what they don't
speak english he's insulting him they
can feel yeah because they're animals
but he's like oh he's still like that
you know what i mean but they ran from
him it just usurps the whole
cruelty-free efforts to eat yeah
guiltless
i guess so free you don't roast you
don't i mean you do roast them you don't
talk [ __ ] before you hand roast them
yeah before you roast you roast them
before you what do they do to wag you
joe they like [ __ ] they talk [ __ ] for
86 hours
they get it drunk every day and they
massage it and they massage them
that's not cruelty to animals that's
living better than a lot of humans they
just have like they're just alcoholics
they have their own cruelty in their
head it's just mentally ill
we just don't know but you know that we
talk about here you guys follow any
nature pages absolutely nature's metal
but only the savage ones though yeah
dude i saw a [ __ ] komodo dragon go up
to a deer that was laying on the ground
and then uh was taking a nap and then
the kids bit well i saw him mid eating
but he had his like paw on the neck and
he pulled the baby deer out of the
uterus first
eats the baby deer and then ate the mom
oh [ __ ] so the [ __ ] deer was just
giving birth it was giving birth yeah
look
the
almost any animal that dies in the hands
of like our like butcher system is way
cruelty free compared to what the [ __ ]
happens in yeah all you do is hang as a
cow and you're like and then there's
that one time and you're done you're
done whereas komodo dragons they like
bite you one time and then they got that
like poison that paralyzes you and then
the deer is just like oh i don't know
why he's getting his ass how about a
crocodile eating you twisting the [ __ ]
around all over a million times doing
the turbine move at least at least
though they die with dignity without
somebody making fun of them that's true
except you got a bunch of [ __ ] dudes
with their [ __ ] cameras like don't
disturb the nature
that's dignity do you guys like lamb
yeah i love that it's delicious i like
when i eat it i go
do you don't eat it right no i never i
don't know i just never did
i think growing up we just never had it
so i don't have a palette for it like i
just never when you eat it does it taste
funny yeah are you familiar with i think
i've only had it like once and i was
like yeah pretty good does it taste
gamey that's what some people said i
don't even know what i don't even know
what gamey tastes like what is it like
lamb yeah i think when you eat um it
just goes to cycle when you eat like
meats that we're normally used to
whether it be like pork beef or chicken
and then you eat a different type of
meat and then you just taste this other
not like bitter ish but uh it's very
animally dangerous yeah
like that like deer tastes like that
lamb tastes like oh um organs organs
taste gaming okay okay yeah i get i get
with that oh it wasn't gaming to me
yeah i got some i got some i think it's
so lean frozen yeah it's got some frozen
elk steaks it just tastes like sirloin
like it's really like lemonade it's
pretty gamey in in in seventh-day
adventists you can eat lamb right mm-hmm
you can eat that that's what's weird
you could eat cow um you could eat
chicken but you can't eat pork yeah just
no pork no bottom feeder fish yeah yeah
that's why i haven't had so many like
different meats so that means you also
haven't eaten shrimp not as not growing
up i didn't have until i was like 19.
yeah i haven't had lobster until i was
in college
i had horse in japan and that was good
too was it good yeah where's this kind
of it's really sweet and juicy the one
that i had are there specific ways to
prepare horse that you wouldn't know it
was just slight creamy like korean
butter sashimi horse what the [ __ ] oh
yeah
just came out like like a plate of like
meat and you just kind of grilled it
yourself like korean bbq stuff is it
colored like meat it's like normal yeah
just look you can't even tell if someone
brought it out you would just think it's
beef huh wow but it doesn't taste like
beef it's a little tougher and leaner
if you're drinking alcohol you're just
talking you would just think you're
eating beef also like what we're used to
right is when we eat like beef like we
always want like fat on it like marbley
flavor whereas like you don't [ __ ]
normally eat like fat ass horse right
like horses are so buff dude they're so
lean they're so buff so the meat is like
you don't get that fat marbliness it's
like just the redness and it's even a
darker thick red which makes it more
like lean and gay nutrition wise is
there more benefit to eating like a lean
horse that's what i heard i actually
heard uh
um there's this one study where like
traditional cultures that ate like horse
like
mongolians or like native americans or
some [ __ ] like that they like had less
heart disease and all this other just
leaner in general well not but when
you're talking about like traditional
like humans surviving and stuff like
that back then it's more about like the
organs like livers for the nutrients and
fat yeah like storing fat if you had a
[ __ ] ton of like if you got like a moose
that's not actually like super that's
not gonna make you last long you need
like fat you know what i'm saying and
the type of cow like the beef that we
eat too it's not natural like they
they're just [ __ ] eating corn all day
and they're full of fat and that's why
they're so delicious because if you've
had like grass-fed just beef where it's
not finished with grain meaning like
sometimes you'll eat grass-fed beef and
you'll see like finished with corn or
whatever right what they do is like they
they they
introduce like corn to their diet at the
end so then they get a little bit of
that fat and it's tastier but if you do
strictly just grass-fed it doesn't taste
as good
when are you allowed to make fun of the
animal when they're like free-range you
can make fun of them but then when
they're finishing them you can't i know
right your plate you could talk maybe
right there he was like they were being
like corn finished like you're supposed
to like keep all that to yourself maybe
that's true it's the stage if they if
they had the cow upside down and then
they go and they had that down finish
him every time and the cows like this
well the cows are already like that but
upside down yeah i think that'd be
pretty sick
and i wonder if that's cruelty though
obvious girl i don't think that i think
cruelty to animal only like applies when
you're torturing like unnecessary things
like you're putting yeah
i don't know i think off of this gordon
ramsay thing
just just to be semi-neutral devil's
advocate yeah
obviously it's like a fans on jk it's
like uh if we say something that's
offensive and they're not into it it's
like low key just don't subscribe like
that's maybe not your cup of tea yeah
but then if you like laugh it's like hey
you're that kind of person too yeah you
know what i'm saying you're my kind of
guy he's a [ __ ] found a piece of [ __ ]
exactly
it's like the spider-man man
so it's not i would never look at
something like that it's like is he
right or wrong it really uh just depends
on what type of person you are and what
perspective you have you know what i'm
saying i don't think he crossed the line
though i don't think that's because
that's the type of person you are
but i think cruelty to animals is like
when you're torturing them physically
putting them through pain like a
thousand of them in a cage yeah and like
they're sick and they're spraying
factory farming spreading diseases all
around bart how would you me let's try
this how would you tell taika about
where his food comes from have you done
that no does he know about like
have you had him go to a petting zoo and
pet the cow oh yeah we went to the
fairway and i'm like this is what you
eat this is beef this is chicken
but i don't know if he's tying it
together did you walk him over get a
chili dog after
and go this is i don't [ __ ] know what
it is but it's it's it's all the animals
you saw today it's a mixture of them the
craziest thing is um
so like i think as a so i think all of
those like [ __ ] [ __ ] ass thoughts i
think they're learning behaviors yeah
because we went to this um uh this
japanese restaurant and then i think the
lady just thought taiko was super cute
so she brought over a bunch of fried
like little crabs like this like whole
[ __ ] crap so it looks like a
cockroach right on a skewer like [ __ ]
10 of them like this right and then she
brought it over and i never want to like
i want taiko to have his own opinions so
when jill was like oh god i was like
just
you know see what he does right because
then because jill looks at it like a
bunch of cockroaches because it looks
freaky and i'm like you look like a like
a chinese guy who wants to eat them all
you want to eat it and he goes sure he
takes it and goes
mmm it's like a potato chip i'm like oh
[ __ ] that's dope so i think a lot of
these like a scary animal like whatever
it's like learned behavior for sure it's
from people who live in such a sterile
environment that like when their food
comes out they don't make the connection
that it's from
like nature hey dude i remember seeing
sardines for the first time because my
mom used to just chop him up and put him
on the plate and then i saw her unroll
that thing and i was like yo what
at least this guy doesn't have his
[ __ ] eyes staring in your god that's
the only thing i don't want to look him
in the eyes and then kill him
[Music]
bye